mangal bonsoir bienvenue à 24,60 cette
visite est liée à la publication en
français de votre plus récent ouvrage je
remballe ma bibliothèque
c'est une belle idée que de remballer sa
bibliothèque j'imagine de l'écrire mon
sens travers la lecture de votre ouvrage
que remballer la bibliothèque c'est un
exercice quand même douloureux il ya
presqu'un deuil associé à cet exercice
une bibliothèque qui est si quelque part
à montréal en entrepôt 35 mille livres
internement prématurée l'internât mais
au moins le corps est à montréal
j'ai dû quitter ma bibliothèque en
france après quinze ans de bonheur mais
vous savez c'est dans l'internât tueur
d'un paradis qu de le quitter de le
perdre et donc bon je suis en train de
songer à cette renaissance de la
bibliothèque à sa résurrection peut-être
au québec
peut-être à la ville de québec ou à
montréal pour la réinstaller comme une
bibliothèque de l'histoire de la lecture
l'histoire de l'élection c'est très
important a décrit d'ailleurs un ouvrage
l'histoire de la vapeur mais une
bibliothèque comme la vôtre c'est au
fond plusieurs bibliothèques
au fil de votre vie dans notre enfance
adolescence vous avez parcouru le monde
donc ces votes votre bibliothèque c'est
un peu votre biographie sur mon ex au
squelette
c'est mon identité ccc qui je suis et
dans les étagères
parce que quand vous l'avez 10 et les
sept bibliothèques parcours plusieurs
bibliothèques de ma vie
je pu ramasser tous et ses brins de
bibliothèque
quand je me suis installé en france est
assez fascinant parce que vous dites je
ne me résigne pas à ce que l'on enfouit
des carrément dans le sol dur s'est
encore envolé mais vous entendez les
livres vous appelez dans votre sommeil
tout en rêvait de vos livres
la ville vous avez lu tous et
renseignements benoit bien sûr bien sûr
non vous savez il y un certain lecteurs
pour qui la position du livre n'est pas
très importante bourget c'était un de
ses lecteurs que vous avez connu
d'ailleurs que j'ai connu à l'ajax ans
je travaillais pour lui je lui ai fait
la lecture à haute voix parce qu'il
était aveugle mais pour moi les et doit
posséder les livres que je lis c'est
pour ça que il m'est difficile de lire
dans une bibliothèque publique parce
qu'on n'a pas le droit de souligner sur
son la paroisse de ramener le livre chez
soi et donc ses livres que que je
possède sondés présence réelle pour moi
dans la bible il ne dirait pas que des
objets rangés sur les étagères cd
présence qui me parlent qu'ils
m'appellent qui m'interpelle mais en
même temps vous êtes vous écrivez ou si
vous avez déjà déclaré les bibliothèques
met en ordre le chaos dimanche
tout à fait on met son poteau me on
appelait bibliothécaire c'est lui qui
met en entre l'univers et ça me paraît
une définition parfaite parce que ce que
nous connaissons du monde c'est le chaos
c'est l'absurdité sur le non sens et
nous prennons c'est cela
les morceaux des connaissances que nous
avons de l'univers que nous mettons dans
les libres et nous les mettons en ordre
alphabétique ou thématiques ou numérique
et est comme ça nous avons un sens d'une
certaine message de l'univers que le
monde nous parle nous dit voilà qui je
suis dans la bibliothèque
nous existons et en même temps votre
premier contact avec une bibliothèque
avec les livres 7 à 3 4 ans je pense
avec votre grand mère
aujourd'hui les enfants du 21e siècle on
délivre encore où certains les heureux
mais en beaucoup d'écrans virtuel pour
vous comme des fantômes oui pour moi
mais je suis suis vieux mais 71 ans
quand même donc j'ai l'habitude de la
lecture de l'imprimé à chaque fois que
la technologie changent les méthodes de
lecture chance ça nous avons changé
quand nous avons passé de la tablette
d'argile aux rouleaux de papyrus du
rouleau de papyrus au codex au parchemin
et ensuite à l'imprimé l'imprimé est
passé à au numérique mais c'est pas que
ce soit la dernière technologie que nous
allons savoir où le libre on parle peu
cheap dont le cerveau est que les
générations à venir pourront lire en
appuyant sur un bouton et créer
mais avant j'avais 35 mes livres à
mettre un entrepôt dans les bois mais
avait dans un appareil électronique on
peut mettre voire plus que 35 milles
seulement que moi pour moi j'ai besoin
de la présence matérielle
je ne crois à la lecture virtuelle je ne
peux je ne crois pas au sexe virtuel je
ne fais au monde virtuel vous avez
parcouru le monde en 1968 vous avez fui
la dictature argentine à banco
je ne pas souffert de la dictature comme
beaucoup de mes jeunes s'adonnent
n'avait pas couru le monde nous avait
néanmoins fait n'avait pas vécu sous la
dictature 1968 est-ce que tu intéressant
quand on lit je remballe ma bibliothèque
on découvre que dans les années 80 pour
la première fois vous avez cru qu ici au
canada parce que vous étiez ici qu'on
pouvait jouer un rôle actif en tant que
citoyen ça se faisait aussi à vous êtes
devenu citoyen canadien louis jour
absolument mais aussi la cuisson b
amoureux de ce mois vous avez découvert
même là les radios de la littérature
québécoise
tout à fait mais dans le temps dans les
années 80 quand je suis arrivé dans une
année j'ai pu lire tout ce qui a été
publié dans cette année au québec
et jamais je pourrais faire ça
aujourd'hui la littérature québécoise à
une éclosion si extraordinaire que je
peux à peine suivre les nouvelles
parutions pour vous le livre la lecture
des livres c'est un espace grand espace
de liberté oui qui nous met aussi et ça
nous met à l'abri des dictatures ça nous
met ya un lien entre le livre en tout
cas y la démocratie en tout à fait mais
ça ne nous met pas à l'abri des
dictatures comme nous le voyons dans le
monde entier ce que la littérature nous
permet de faire et de nommer les
injustices à travers de la littérature
nous pouvons apprendre l'un d'elles un
pâtit avec les autres nous pouvons voir
dans les personnages des fictions depuis
la la littérature ancienne jusqu'à nos
jours
comment ces personnages réagissent
souffre vive et apprendre de comment
vivre et pour cela la littérature nous
aide à comprendre notre monde et notre
situation qui aujourd'hui est gravissime
dans sa peut former des citoyens c'est à
peu près ce que vous et qu'à tout à fait
ouais je crois que c'est la seule façon
de former des citoyens c'est à travers
l'éducation dont
à travers de la lecture donc à travers
de la littérature nous pouvons je crois
nous sauver nous mêmes de ce suicide
collective que l'on nous prépare
par le biais de la lecture la lecture la
connaissance des suicides collectifs et
en quoi l'environnement étant la
consommation la vendait tout cela c'est
bizarre nous le savons trop on n'a pas
besoin de nous l'apprendre nous savons
que nous sommes au bord du précipice et
peut-être avec une éducation de la
lecture nous pourrons donner pas en
arrière pour retrouver le bon chemin et
c'est sans doute pour cela que les
dictateurs des pierres première chose
qu'ils font c'est de supprimer la
liberté d'expression les avants avec la
liberté d'écrire et donc de lee a brûlé
libre tuer les écrivains
restreindre la liberté de création
artistique c'est la première chose
qu'ils font ils vont pas se prendre aux
banquiers ou aux médecins
à berlin on voit là où on appelait les
livres on a tout à fait non seulement à
berlin on les a brûlés au canada aussi
raté nous comment vous savez il y à des
groupes extrémistes qui ont trouvé que
par exemple les oeuvres de anne hébert
est montrée trop la sexualité ou
tremblay par exemple et il ya eu deux
cas où ces livres ont été interdits
retirer des bibliothèques publiques
nationales et moraux de censure qu'il ne
fonctionne jamais je vous avais suivi à
l'époque à la fin des années 90 6 y
avait un grand débat pour d'autres
bibliothèques nationales
vous qui avez été directeur de cette
bibliothèque en argentine partir l'un
des plus importantes depuis tout elle du
monde que bourget souci avait dirigé il
si on dira c'est trop cher on n'a pas
les moyens et c'est devenu comme un
joyau cette bibliothèque l'heure dite
heureuse d'important pour une session
son identité nom et la bibliothèque
représente l'identité du social même
ceux qui ne lisent pas doivent respecter
ce symbole de leur identité parce que
c'est la mémoire d'une société tout ce
que nous savons sur nous mêmes et dans
cette bibliothèque une bibliothèque et
de lieux des évidences j'ai évoqué un
instant les fameux dictateurs est ce que
vous vous regardez le monde et vous êtes
un tiers vous avez parlé de suicide
collectif
en fait on parce que les dictateurs ont
la cote maintenant à deux parties sont
adoubés par quelqu'un comme 30
oui je les grandes émotions et populisme
qui monte qui est si dangereux parce que
le paradoxe du populisme c'est que ce
que le populisme ne respecte pas c'est
le peuple c'est un mouvement contre les
êtres humains comme être humain ça ne
respecte pas l'intelligence individuelle
ça ne respecte pas les désirs collective
ça va vers ce qui est plus mesquin le
plus égoïste de l'être humain
et avec cela on ne peut pas construire
une société qui est censé d'être le lieu
où nous retrouvons pourparlers pour
créer des choses nouvelles
est-ce que je peux proposer un petit je
sais pas si vous allez vouloir
j'aime jouer à wim van est ce que les
personnages de la littérature qui vous
font penser par exemple à trump ou de
sannois maduro mais là je vous conseille
livre extraordinaire de stephen green
plate de jeff shapiro qui s'appelle
tyrannie qui est en étude des tyrans
dans les oeuvres de shakespeare et sans
mentionner 30
ça explique la montée de richard iii ou
de mcb est au pouvoir et et ça explique
comment ces gens réagissent et comment
la soif de pouvoir
les dévore donc nous pouvons apprendre
cela dans la littérature que pas
seulement le portrait du dictateur
sinon notre responsabilité en tant que
citoyen parce que c'est à cause de nous
que ces choses se passent nous ne sont
pas des innocents quand il y à cette
montée du populisme dans le monde
conduire à cette violence contre les
droits des l'homme et de la femme c'est
nous les responsables et la littérature
peut nous apprendre des stratégies pour
lutter contre en même temps vous qui
avez parcouru le monde qui avait eu
beaucoup qui écrivait beaucoup quand on
voit ces phénomènes de migration être
réprimés n'est ce pas de manière
violente et c'est là tout simplement
parce que on veut préserver
c'est acquises ces héros que ce soit en
europe ou à la fonction du mix et qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire
il faut se demander préserver quoi est
d'abord il faut se demander qui nous
sommes parce que nous sommes tous des
nomades
il y as peut-être quelques représentants
des peuples autochtones qui peuvent se
dire vraiment de la terre de cet espace
mais tous les autres sont venus de
quelque part ailleurs
nous sommes une espèce nomades et donc
nous devons trouver une solution pour
tous ces mouvements des gens qui se font
mais depuis la nuit des siècles donc les
fermer les portes ne ne sert à rien
parce que c'est pas que en fermant la
porte en construisant mur
nous excluons les autres c'est nous qui
nous excluons et personnes comme dit le
capitaine nemo à la fin des l'île
mystérieuse
aucune personne peut vivre seul et il
dit de lui même je meurs d'avoir cru
qu'on pouvait survivre seul c'est là
dessus qu'on va se laisser un berthod a
manqué l on va souhaiter que votre
bibliothèque renesse quelque part à
montréal merci beaucoup ma grand-mère
dirait des baux l'oeuvre à l'oreille de
dieu merci merci